I spoke today on the phone with the
Chinese Prime Minister Li Keqiang we
both agreed that the fight against
coronavirus is a global one and that we
need to support each other in times of
need
China has not forgotten that in January
when China was the center of the virus
outbreak the European Union helped we
donated rapidly more than 50 tons of
protective equipment I remember very
well my phone call with the Chinese
Prime Minister in those days today we
are the center of the corona virus
pandemic and we need protective
equipment ourselves we are ramping up
our production we're converting new
production lines but this needs several
weeks and in the meantime we are
grateful for support from China the
Prime Minister announced that China is
ready to provide 200,000 n95 masks two
million surgical masks and 50,000
testing kits
these can be shipped to Europe
immediately our Commissioner and the
Chinese Trade Minister are implementing
this this support is highly valued and
we are grateful for it